she takes three years off of sex work
then she gets the opportunity to be an
influencer these women never want to do
hard jobs they never want to actually do
what it takes to not put their ass on
the internet and they always go back to
it that's why men get so frustrated when
you get these girls that do these ho
apology tours because they always end up
going back when they actually have to do
work half of these chicks are just too
lazy to work a normal job McDonald's is
hiring you could waitress you could
serve you could I'm sure there a library
hiring down the street from you but they
want Easy Money they've never had to do
what it takes to earn hard money because
they've always monetized their beauty in
some way